[Music]
all right let's go to tyler in la hey
tyler how are you
hey how's it how are you guys doing
great what's going on
hey um so i had a quick question i um
i'm born and raised in hawaii yes i just
moved out to
um
california recently i have a home
in hawaii and i have a business in
hawaii
and uh we're looking to buy an another
house up here in california
but
my question is
i've been working less and less and less
um with this whole
um
you know remote working and i'm getting
a little itchy to either
you know
like get a job up here or start a new
business up here or
i don't know if i should just burn the
ships in hawaii and sell the house and
sell the business i mean i'm just
looking for some outside uh
you know opinion on
on what maybe i should do because all
this is all this is uh like new to me
yeah so my wife's from california so
we decided when the pandemic hit in
hawaii or in the world i guess um i was
working remotely and then we're like man
we have a chance to move you know
because you know we're still making
money with me not you know being out and
about in the field and stuff so
we decided to do it and uh you know here
we are and i feel like i got one leg on
both sides of the fence here and uh
you know
i mean that's basically the question is
uh
um
you know maybe some guidance on uh
on um what they should do yeah all right
give me a little bit more information
what's your business
in hawaii
um it's a it's a it's like an rmr
company
so
it's got recurring monthly revenue so it
makes
a lot of money it does like a million a
year it's a really good company i
promoted one of my guys to uh a general
manager and i really helped them and
then now i'm just doing less and less
you know i have zoom meetings with them
on friday and
mondays but i mean i'm just doing less
and less so are you planning to go back
to hawaii
yeah i go back all the time i've only
been up here for like three months my
wife's from here so gotcha from here
okay so you have a house in hawaii a
house in california and you go back and
forth kind of
well no i own a house in hawaii and i
wanted to buy a house in california but
i mean california is just so stupid
right now i had to give the guy a whole
year of rent so i gave him like 50 grand
so we could just get to california to
try and buy a house here got to so we're
looking around buy a house here in
california now when i get the house in
california i'll put my molly house on
it's either i sell it or i'll put it on
like a 15-year fix and refinance it
after we
close over here because the whole goal
is my kids i want my kids in school up
here because maui with coverage or
hawaii with covet is so bad that it's
like that's why we that's why we came up
here gotcha okay so
are you completely debt free
oh no i hope yet all right
are you familiar with what we teach
i just heard about you guys and i've
been listening to you guys um
my father-in-law is
you know he bought a house in arizona
and he doesn't owe anything and he's got
a house in hawaii he doesn't know
anything and he's the one that told me
about you guys so i've been listening
for a couple of weeks and then i just
figured i'd call cool well here's the
thing tyler and i'm gonna let george
jump in here but i just want to start by
saying this it sounds like you need some
goals
you feel a little bored you need some
goals and here's the great news we're
about to give you some goals oh yeah
we're about to give you some goals tyler
so just get a pen and paper george take
it away so you know zig ziglar says if
you aim at nothing you'll hit it every
time and right now you know you've got
the business running on the side and
you're kind of aiming at nothing but it
sounds like you do have financial goals
you want to buy a house you let that you
you made that clear but you've got a
pile of debt here how much debt do we do
you have total
um i don't
we only i have a brand new
uh 2021 black on black tahoe for my wife
that's elise
and then i've got my truck and then i've
got a couple of vans for the guys
so you got dead on the vans do you know
how much the total
is i'd say like
maybe like 50 grand
50 grand that feels low for what you
just laid out there i mean the 2021
tahoe alone feels like that could be 50
grand
yeah but it's a lease so it's only like
16 000 is all it is uh what's what do
you know what the early buyout would be
i don't know that yet no i don't okay
so what is your income
um well i i take 150 000 from the
company
and uh my wife is amazing and she takes
uh fifty thousand she doesn't do
anything in the business but she takes
fifty thousand
so two hundred thousand a year okay
and uh i want this side hustle now that
we're talking about this i want this to
be to pay off this debt i mean you guys
have a great income obviously you're in
a high cost of living area and so it
feels more difficult to do anything
because like you said it's just stupid
right now uh but i want this side also
whatever it is you seem like you're an
entrepreneurial guy is that right
absolutely i don't think i could ever
work for something yeah i don't i can't
picture you taking a side hustle 14
years i've had this business so wow well
it's successful so whatever you're doing
you're good at it and so is there
something you could spin up in
california to bring an income and pay
off this debt really quickly
well that's the thing like i said i
could burn the [ __ ] if i sell the
if i sell the house in hawaii
um the house in hawaii is worth a
million dollars i owe like 375 on it so
i mean i don't know if i should keep the
business well do you need the house in
hawaii
well eventually you know i wanted to be
able to be in hawaii for summers and
then be up here during the year
that's the goal do you need the house
that big in hawaii could you would you
sell it and then you could downsize and
get something smaller later on in life
yeah sure you could i like this i like
this idea only because i don't know how
much you're using this house what what's
going on with the house when you're not
there
well it's rented right now for 5 000 a
month well that's not bad it's rented
yeah it's rented right now
so yeah there's a lot going on here
which ran up here was four grand so
i did uh
i had to pay him a whole year
yeah well what i would tell you as far
as the goals go is i want you to follow
the baby steps that we teach which is
have a thousand dollars for a starter
emergency fund which i imagine you have
that uh and then baby step two is where
we pay off all the debt and that means
no more leasing cars that means no more
debt on the work fans uh i want you just
live a debt-free lifestyle because if
you do that you're going to be so
unbelievably wealthy you're going to be
bored out of your mind i can't wait to
see how bored you are once you don't
have any payments in your life and you
can do whatever you want and so once
we've got that we can get the emergency
fund start investing and i don't know
where you're at with that side of things
but you i want you to do things in order
so that you feel the progress well the
whole why behind what we teach tyler is
the quickest path to building wealth
that's the why so we have seven baby
steps and george just referenced that
really quickly
the why of the baby steps is to get you
to wealth true wealth which means
debt-free wealth where you own
everything and you can do anything you
want to businesses houses you can do
whatever you want give outrageously once
you stay on the line i'm going to have
austin get you registered for our game
plan event this is coming up
in september september 28th i'll be
speaking along with george dave ramsey
and we're gonna give you a game plan for
your money this is exactly what you need
right now now tyler it's gonna give you
the steps and the plan that you need
to reach your goal so stay on the line
we'll get you registered for that event